[موسيقى]
عبير الرويلي سيده سعوديه من مدينه عرعر
بمنطقه الحدود الشماليه السعوديه
دابت على مدى ثلاث سنوات في خدمه الحجاج
القادمين برا من العراق عبر منفذ جديده
عرعر برفقه اثنين من ابنائها
[موسيقى]
ثالثه سنوات اقدم
منفذ جديده عرعر سوى في موسم الحج او كذلك
في موسم العمره وخاصه في شهر رمضان والحمد
لله احس بسعاده كبيره وانا اخدم ضيوف
الرحمن لدرجه اني عكست حبه تطوع لاولادي
ولمن هم حولي محمد ابن الثامنه عشره عاما
واخاه وليد يشاركان والدتهما مساعده
الحجاج حيث اخذ منها حب المساعده والتطوع
في عمل الخير شرف لي اقدم ضيوف الرحمن
ومثل وطني في مجال تطوع بافضل صوره انا
سعيد اليوم في خدمه الحجاج في منفذ
الجريده عرعر اقدم لهم المساعده
والمشروبات الساخنه والبارده
وان شاء الله يصلون الى المشاعر المقدسه
بسلام امنين حاب اشكر اثنين انا امي وابوي
الله يحفظهم لي هم اللي يحفزوني على
التطوع هذا وخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
[موسيقى]
عشرات المتطوعين والمتطوعات يقومون على
خدمه الحجاج بشكل يومي طوال فتره التفويج
عبر هذا المنفذ من منفذ جديده عرعر على
الحدود السعوديه العراقيه
جزاعا معصيع العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات